The following and content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: I'm
basically an engineer.
And I'm working on
speech recognition.
And so you may wonder, so
what is there to work on?
Because you have a cell
phone in your pocket,
and you speak to it, and Siri
answers you and everything.
And the whole thing is
working very basic principles.
You start with a signal.
It goes to signal processing.
There's some pattern
classification.
Of course, deep
neural nets as usual.
And so this recognizes
the message.
This recognizes
what you are saying,
so the question is, what is it
that is fighter of the boat?
Why not keep going, and try
just to improve the error rates,
and improve them
basically step by step?
Because we have a
good thing going.
We have something which
is already out there.
And it's working.
But you may know
the answer, so this
is, imagine that you are, sort
of, skiing or going on a sled.
And suddenly, you
come somewhere.
And you have to start pushing.
You don't want to do that,
but you do it for the reason,
because there may be some--
another kind of slope going out
there.
And that's the way I feel
about the speech recognition.
So basically, sometimes we
need to push a little bit up
and maybe go slightly
out of our comfort zone
in order to get further.
Speech is not what we are--
it's not the thing
which we are using
for communicating with Siri.
Speech is this.
Basically, people
speak the way I do.
They hesitate.
There's a lot of
fillers, interruptions.
And I don't finish
the sentences.
I speak with a strong
accent, and so on.
I become excited,
and so on, and so on.
And we would like to
put a machine there
instead of the other person.
Basically, this is what a
speech recognition ultimately
is, right?
I mean, and actually, if you see
what government is supporting,
what the big companies
are working on,
this is what we
are worried about.
We are worried about
the real speech
produced by real people in the
real communications by speech.
And you know, I didn't mention
all the disturbing things
like noises, and so on, and so
on, but we will get into that.
So I believe that
we don't only need
signal processing, and
information theory,
and machine
learning, but we also
need the other disciplines.
And this is where you
guys are coming in.
So that's what I believe in.
We should be working
together, engineering and life
sciences working together.
At least we should try.
We should at least
try to be-- we
engineers should be try to
inspired by life sciences.
And as far as
inspiration is concerned,
I have a story to start with.
There was a guy who won the
lottery by using numbers 1, 2,
3, 6, 7, 49.
And they said, well, this is
of course unusual sequence
of numbers, so they say, how
did you ever get to that?
He says, I'm the first child.
My mother was my
mother's second marriage
and my father's third marriage.
And I was born on
the 6th of July.
And of course, 6 by 7 is 49.
And that's sometimes I
feel, I'm getting this sort
of inspiration from you people.
I may not get it right.
I may not get it right, but as
long as it works, I'm happy.
You know, I'm not being
paid for being smart
and being knowledgeable
about biology.
I'm being, really, paid for
making something which works.
Anyways, so this is
just the warm up.
I thought that you will
still be drinking a coffee,
so I decided to
start with a joke.
But anyway, but it's
an inspiring joke.
I mean, it's about inspiration.
And I would maybe point out
to some of the inspiration
points, which I, of course,
didn't get it right,
but still, it was working.
Why do we have audition?
Josh already told
us-- because we
want to survive in this world.
I mean, this is a little ferret
or whatever, and there is--
he's getting something now.
And there is a object.
And ferret is worrying,
is this something
I should be friendly
with or I should--
it should be something
which I run away.
So what is the message
in this signal?
Is it a danger or
is a opportunity?
Well, the same way,
how do we survive
in this world as human beings?
So there is my wife who has
some message in her head.
And so she wants to
tell me, eat vegetables,
they are good for you,
so she's using speech.
And speech is
actually amazing sort
of mechanism for sharing
the experiences and for--
actually, without
speech, we wouldn't
be where we are, I
can guarantee you,
because that allows us to tell
the other people things what
they should do without
going through much trouble
like a ferret with the bird.
That we may not
have to be eaten,
maybe we just die a little early
if we don't get this right,
if we don't get this message.
So she says this thing, and
hopefully, I get the message.
So this is what
speech is about, but I
wanted to say, the speech
is an important thing,
because it allows us to
communicate abstract ideas
like good for you.
And that's sort of not only
vegetable, vegetable is saying,
but a lot of abstract ideas
can be conveyed by speech.
And that's why I think
it's kind of exciting.
Why do we work on machine
recognition of speech?
Well, first one is just
like Edmund Hillary
said, because it's there.
They are asking, why did
you climb Mount Everest?
He said, well,
because it's there.
I mean, it's a challenge, right?
Spoken language is one of
the most amazing things,
I already told you
before, of human race
so there would be
hell if we can't build
a machine which understands it.
And we don't have an
easy time so far yet.
In addition, when you
are addressing speech,
you are really addressing
the generic problems
which we have in processing
of other cognitive signals.
And we touched it to some
extent during this panel,
because, you know, problems
which we have in speech,
we have the similar
problems in perceiving
images and perceiving smells.
All these cognitive
signals, basically, machines
are not very good at it.
Let's face it.
Machines can add 10 billion
numbers very quickly,
but they cannot tell my
grandmother from the monkey,
right?
I mean, so this is
actually important thing.
There are also practical
applications, obviously--
access to information.
Voice interaction with
machines extracting information
from speech, given how much
speech is out there now with--
I don't know how
much we are adding
every second through the
YouTube and that sort of things,
but there's a lot
of speech out there.
It would be good if
information can actually
extract information from that.
And I tell always the students,
there is a job security.
It's not going to be solved
during your lifetime,
certainly not during mine.
I mean, sort of, if
you get into it--
in addition, I mean, I know
that this is maybe on YouTube,
but also, if you don't like
it, you can get fantastic jobs.
There is a half of
the IBM group ended up
on the Wall Street making
insane amount of money.
So I mean, you
know, what skills we
should get in recognizing
speech, working on the speech,
can be also applied
in other areas.
Obviously it can be applied in
vision, and so on, and so on.
Speech has been produced
to be perceived.
Here is Roman Jakobson,
the great Harvard, MIT guy,
passed away unfortunately.
He would be now a
hundred and something.
He says, we speak in
order to be heard,
in order to be understood.
Speech has been produced
to be perceived.
And over the millennia
of the human evolution,
it evolved this way
so that it reflects
properties of human hearing.
And so I'm very
much also with Josh.
If you build up a machine
which recognizes speech,
you may be verifying some of the
theories of speech perception.
And I'll point out
that along the way.
How do I know that the speech
evolved to fit the hearing
and not the other way around?
I got some big people arguing
over that, because they say,
you don't know, I mean,
basically, but I know.
I think.
Well, I think that
I know, right?
Every single organ which is
used for speech production
is also used for something
much more useful,
like, sort of typically,
eating and breathing.
So this is the organs of speech
production-- lungs, the lips,
teeth, nose, and velum,
and so on, and so on.
Everything is being used for
some life-sustaining functions,
including speaking.
So I know that it's not
the same in hearing.
Hearing has evolved
to hear, for hearing.
Maybe there are some
organs of balance,
and that sort of thing,
but mostly, you do hear.
In the speech, everything,
what is being used,
has been used for--
it's used for
something else also,
so clearly, we just
learned how to speak
because we had the
appropriate hardware there,
and we learned how to use it.
So in order to get
the message, you
use some cognitive
aspects, which
I won't be talking much about.
So you have to use
the common language.
You have to have some
context of the conversation.
common set of priors,
some common experience, and
so on, and so on, but mainly
what I will be
talking about, you
need the reliable signal
which carries the message,
because the message
is in the signal.
It's also in your
head, but the signal
supports what is
happening in your head.
So how much information
is in speech signal?
This is, I have stolen I believe
from George Miller, I think.
So if you look at
Shannon's theory,
I mean, there will be about
80 kilobytes per second.
And indeed, you can
generate a reasonable signal
without being very
smart about it
just by coding it to 11 bits
at 8 kilohertz per second, 80
kilobits per second.
This verifies it.
So this is how much information
might be in the signal.
How much is in the
speech is actually very--
it's, sort of, not very
clear, but at least we
can estimate it to some extent.
If you say, I would like to
transcribe the signal in terms
of the speech sounds,
phonemes, so there is maybe
about 40 to 49 phonemes,
or something, 41 phonemes.
So if you look at
the entropy of that,
it comes to about
80 bits per second.
So there is three orders
of magnitude difference.
If you push a
little bit further--
indeed, I mean, if you speak
with about 150,000 words, that
means about 80 bits,
30 words per minute,
again, it comes to
less than 100 bits.
So there's, as I
said, there's a number
of ways how you can argue about
this amount of information.
If you start thinking about
dependencies between phonemes,
it can go as low as
10, 20 bits per second.
No question that there is much
more information in the signal
than it is in useful message
which we would like to get out.
And we'll get into that.
Because what is in the
message, there is not only
information about the
message, but there
is a lot of other information.
There's information about health
of the speaker, about which
language the speaker
is using, what
are-- what emotions,
there is who is speaking,
speaker-dependent
information, what is the mood,
and so on, and so on.
And there is a lot
of noise coming
from around, reverberations.
We talk about it quite
a lot in the morning,
all kinds of other noises.
So what I call
noise in general, I
call everything
what we don't want
besides the signal, which,
in speech recognition,
is the message.
So when I talk
about the noise, it
can be information about who is
speaking, about their emotions,
about the fact that
maybe my voice is going,
and so on, and so on.
To my mind, purpose
of perception is
get the information
which carries--
get the signal which carries
the desired information
and suppress the noise,
eliminate the noise.
So the purpose of perception,
being a little bit vulgar
about it, is how to get rid
of most of the information
very quickly, because otherwise,
your brain would go bananas.
So you basically want to focus
on what you want to hear,
and you want to ignore, if
possible, everything else.
And it's not, of course,
easy, but we discuss that
again in the morning, about some
techniques how to go about it.
And I will mention a
few more techniques
which we are working on.
But this a key thing,
is, purpose of perception
is to get what you need and
not to get what you don't need,
because otherwise, your
brain would be too busy.
Speech happens in many--
it's a very simple example.
Speech happens in many,
many environments.
And there is a lot of
stuff happening around it,
so the very simple
example, which I actually
used when I was giving a talk to
some grandmothers in the Czech
Republic is that, what
you can already use
is the fact that things
happen at different levels.
And they happen at
different frequencies,
so perception is selective.
Every perceptual mode is
selective and attends only
to part of the world.
You know, we don't
hear the radio--
we don't see the radio waves.
And we don't hear
the ultrasound,
and so does all the lower
elements, and so on, and so on.
So there are
different frequencies,
different sound intensities
are in the first approximation.
This is what you may use.
If something is too
weak, I don't care.
If something has too
high frequencies,
I don't care, and
so on, and so on.
There are also different
spectral and temporal dynamics
to speech, which we are
learning about that quite a lot.
It happens at different
locations of the space.
Again, this is the reason why
we have a spatial directivity.
That's why we have two ears.
That's why we have a
specifically-shaped ears,
and so on, and so on.
There are also other
cognitive aspects,
I mean, sort of, like,
the selective attention.
Again, we talk about
it, that people
appear to be able to
modify the properties
of your cognitive
processing depending
on what you want to listen to.
And my friend Nima
Mesgarani with Eddie Chang,
who was supposed to
be here instead of me,
just had a major paper in Nature
about that, and so on, and so
on.
There's a number of ways how
we can modify the selectivity.
We talk about this sharpening
the cochlear filters,
I mean, depending on the
signal from the brain.
So speech happens like
this, start with a message.
You have a linguistic code,
maybe 50 bits per second.
There are some motor controls.
Speech production comes
to a speech signal,
which has three orders of
magnitude larger information
content.
Through speech perception
and cognitive processes,
we get, somehow, back
to the linguistic code
and extract the
message, so this is
important-- from the small,
low bit-rate, to high bit-rate,
to the low bit-rate.
In production,
actually, I don't want
to pretend it happens
in such a linear way.
There are also
feedbacks, so there
is a feedback from you listen to
yourself when you are speaking.
You can control how you speak.
And you can also
actually change the code,
because you realize,
oh, I should have
said it somehow differently.
In speech perception, again, we
just talked about it, you can,
if the message is
not getting through,
you may be able to tune
the system in some ways.
You may be changing
the things, you know?
And you may also use the
very mechanical techniques,
as I told you, close the
window, or walk away.
There is also feedback
through the dialogue,
so from-- between
message and message,
depending what
I'm hearing, I may
be asking a different
kind of question,
so which also modifies
the message of the sender.
How do we produce speech?
So we speak in order
to be heard, in order
to be understood.
So very quickly,
I want to go back
to something which people
already forgot a big way, which
is Homer Dudley.
He was a great researcher
at Bell Laboratories
before the Second World War.
He retired I think
sometime early in '50s.
He passed away in the '60s.
He was saying message is in the
movements of the vocal tract
which modulates the carrier,
so message in the speech
is not in fundamental
frequency, it's
not the way you are
exciting your vocal tract.
Message is how you shape the
organs of speech production.
Proof for that is that you
can whisper and you can still
understand, so you don't--
how you excite the vocal
tract is secondary.
How do you generate this
audible carrier is secondary.
You know, you can use
the artificial larynx,
so there is this idea,
there's a message.
A message is being--
goes through modulator into
carrier, comes out as speech.
So this modulation actually
has been used a long time ago,
and excuse me for being maybe
a little bit simplistic,
but it's actually, in
some ways, interesting.
So this was the speech
production mechanism
which was developed in some
time in the 18th century
by the guy Johannes Wolfgang
Ritter von Kempelen.
And he actually had it right.
The only problem is
nobody trusted him,
because he also invented
Mechanical Turk, which
was playing the chess.
And so he was
caught as a cheater,
so when he was showing
his synthesizer,
nobody believed him.
But anyways, he was
definitely a smart guy.
So he used already the
principle which is now used.
This is a linear model of speech
production developed actually
before the Second World
War, really, again,
Bell Laboratories
should get the credit.
I believe this is stolen
from Dudley's paper.
So there is a source,
and you can change it.
It periodic signals
out random noise,
if you are producing voice
signal or unvoice signal.
And then there is
a resonance control
which goes into amplifier,
and it produces the speech.
So this is the key here,
this a key to the point
that Dudley developed
for this called a voder.
And he trained the lady who
spent a year or something
to play it.
It was played like a organ.
And she was changing
the resonance properties
of this system here.
And she was creating excitation
by pushing on a pitch pedal
and switching on the big--
on the wrist bar.
And if it works well, we may
even be able to make the sound.
This is a test.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Will you please make the voder
say, for our Eastern listeners,
good evening, Radio--
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
This is a real--
- --audience.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: --speech.
- Good evening, radio audience.
HYNEK HERMANSKY: This is--
- And now, for our
Western listeners,
say, good afternoon,
radio audience.
- Good afternoon,
[END PLAYBACK]
HYNEK HERMANSKY:
Good enough, right?
I mean, sort of--
so already, 1940s,
This was the demonstrated
at a trade fair.
And the lady was trained so
well that, in the '50s, when
Dudley was retiring,
they brought her in.
She was already retired
a long time ago.
And she still could play it.
How the speech works--
I mean, maybe-- oh, I wanted
to jump this, but anyways,
let's go very
quickly through that.
So this is a speech signal.
This is a acoustic signal.
It changes in-- this is a
sinusoid, high pressure,
low pressure, high
pressure, low pressure.
If you put somewhere
in the in the path,
some barrier, what happens is
you generate a standing wave.
A standing wave
stands in a space.
And there are high pressures,
low pressures, high pressures,
low pressures.
And the frequency depends
on the frequency--
I mean, the size of
this standing wave
depends on the
frequency of the signal.
So if I put it into
something like a vocal tract,
which we have here--
so this is a glottis.
This is where it gets exciting.
This is a very simple
model of vocal tract.
And here I have a lips.
So it takes certain time to
provide this through the tube.
And the tube will have a maximum
velocity at certain point for--
so that it will be
resonating in a quarter
wavelength of the signal, 3/4 of
the wavelength of the signals,
in 5/4 of the wavelength of the
signal, and so on, and so on.
So we can compute
which frequencies
this tube will be resonating.
This is a very simplistic
way of producing speech,
but you can generate reasonable
speech sounds with that.
So if we start putting a
constriction there somewhere,
which emulates the way,
very simple the way
how we can speak by moving
the tongue against the palate
or making of constrictions
in the speech--
so when the tube
is open like this,
it resonates at
500, 1,500, 2,500
if the tube is 17
centimeters long,
which is a typical length
for the vocal tract.
So if I put a constriction
here, everything
moves down because there is
such a thing like perturbation
theory, which says
that, if you are putting
a constriction through the point
of the maximum velocity, which
is, of course, at the opening,
all the modes will go down.
And as you go on, basically,
the whole thing keeps changing.
The point is that, almost
in every position of the,
say, this tongue, all
the resonance frequencies
are changing, so the whole
spectrum is being affected.
And that may become useful
to explain something later.
But we go like this.
At the end, you end up, again,
in the same frequencies.
These are called nomograms.
And they will be heavily
worked on at the Speech Group
at MIT and at Stockholm.
So you can see how the
formants are moving.
And you can see that, for every
position of the [INAUDIBLE],,
here we have a distance of a
constriction from the lips.
For every position, we are
having all the formants moving,
so information about what I'm
doing with my vocal organs
is actually at all frequencies,
all audible frequencies
in different ways, but
it's there everywhere.
It's not a single frequency
which would carry information
about something.
All the audible frequencies
carry information about speech.
That's important.
You can also look at
it and you can say,
you know, what is the--
where the front
cavity resonates,
the back cavity resonates.
Again, this front
cavity resonance
may become interesting a little
bit later if we get to that.
But this is a very simplistic
model of the speech production,
but pretty much contains all the
basic elements of the speech.
Point here is that, depending on
the length of the vocal tract,
even when you keep the
constriction at the same
position-- this is how long
is this front part before
the construction is--
so all the resonances
are moving,
but a shorter vocal tract, like
the children's vocal tract,
or even in a number of
females, they typically
have a shorter vocal
tract than the males,
there's a different
number of resonances.
So if somebody is telling
you the information
is in the formants of
speech, question it,
because it's actually impossible
to generate the same speech
being two different
people, especially
having two different
lengths of the vocal tract.
And we get into it when we talk
about the speaker dependencies.
Second part is-- of the
equation is hearing.
So we speak in order
to be heard, in order
to be understood.
And again, thanks to Josh, he
spent more than sufficient time
explaining you enough
what I wanted to say.
I will just add something--
some very, very small things.
So just to summarize,
Josh was telling you
the theory works basically
like a bank of bandpass filters
with a changing
frequency and output
depending on sound
level intensity.
There are many
caveats to that, but I
mean, in a first
approximation, I 100%
agree this is enough
for us to follow
for all the rest of the talk.
Second thing which Josh
mentioned very briefly,
but I want to stress it, because
it is important, firing rates--
because you know the
cochlea communicates
with the rest of the
system through the firings,
through the impulses.
Firing rates on
the auditory nerve
are of the order of 1 kilohertz
every one millisecond.
But as you go up and
up in the system,
already here on the colliculus
is maybe order of magnitude
less.
And the order in the
level of auditory cortex
is 2 orders of magnitude less.
So of course, I mean, you know,
this is how the brain works.
I mean, so here we have
from periphery up to cortex,
but also, I think it was
mentioned very briefly,
if you look at it, number of
neurons increase more than
actually decrease in the firing
rates, because if we have--
again, those are just
orders of magnitude--
100,000 neurons maybe on
the level of auditory nerve,
or colliculus nucleus, and you
have 100 million neurons maybe
on the level of the brain.
And this can become
handy later, when,
if I get all the way
to the end of the talk,
I will recall this
piece of information.
Another thing which was
mentioned a number of times
is that there are not the
only connections from ear,
from the periphery to
the brain, but there
is, by some estimates,
many, many more--
I mean, again, I mean
the estimates vary,
but this is something which I
have heard somewhere-- maybe
there is maybe almost 10
times more connections
going from brain to the ear
than from the ear to the brain.
And typically, the
nature hardly ever
builds anything
without a reason,
so there must be
some reason for that.
And perhaps we
will get into that.
Josh didn't talk much about the
level of the-- on the cortex.
So what's happening on the
lower levels, on the periphery?
They are just these
simple increases
of auditory-- of firing rate.
There is a certain
enhancement of the changes.
So at the beginning of the
tone-- this is a tone--
the beginning of
the tone, there is
more firing on auditory nerve.
At the end of the tone,
there is some deflection.
But when you look at a
higher level of the cortex,
all these wonderful
curves, which
are sort of increasing
with intensity
like it would if you had
a simple bandpass filter,
start looking quite differently.
So we measure
majority-- what I heard,
the majority of the
cortical neurons
are selective to certain levels.
Basically, the firing
increases to a certain level,
and then it decreases again.
And they are, of course,
selective at different levels.
Also, I mean, you don't see,
just these simple things
like here, that your firing
starts as a tone starts.
But they are neurons like
that, but there are also
neurons which just are
interested at the beginning
of the signal.
There are neurons which
are interested in beginning
and ends.
There are neurons which
are interested only
at the ends of the signals,
and so on, and so on.
Receptive fields, again, has
been mentioned already before.
Just as we have a receptive
field in the visual cortex,
we have also receptive
fields in auditory cortex.
Here we don't have the--
here we have a frequency and a
time, unlike x and y, receptive
fields which are
typical, sort of,
first thing you are
hearing about when you
talk about visual perception.
They come in all
kinds of colors.
They tend to be
quite long, meaning
they can be sensitive for
about quarter of the second--
not all of them,
but certainly, there
are many, many different
cortical receptive fields.
So some people are
suggesting, given the richness
of the neurons in
auditory cortex,
it's a very legal
thing to suggest
that maybe the sounds are
processing in following way,
not only that you
do the frequency
analysis in the cochlea, but
then, on the higher levels,
you are creating many
pictures of the outside world.
And then, of course, only
the question is here,
if answer, this is Murray
Sachs' paper from their labs,
from Johns Hopkins in 1988.
They just simply said
pattern recognition,
but I believe there
is a mechanism which
picks up the best streams
and leaves out not so
useful things, but
the concept was here
around for a long time.
So this was physiology 101.
Psychophysics is saying that you
play the signals to listeners,
and you ask them what they hear.
But we want to know what is
the response of the organism
to the incoming stimulus, so
simply, you play the stimulus
and you ask what
is the response.
First thing which you can ask,
do you hear something or not?
And you already will discover
some interesting stuff.
Hearing is not
equally-sensitive everywhere.
It's selective.
And it's more
sensitive in the area
somewhere between
1 and 4 kilohertz.
It's much less sensitive
at the lower frequencies.
This is a threshold.
On the threshold level--
here's another
interesting thing.
If you just apply the signals
in different ears, as long
as the signals happen within a
certain period, about a couple
of hundred millisecond,
and if couple of hundred
millisecond you hear from
your ear would be more often,
the thresholds are half.
Basically, neither
of these signals
would be heard if you
applied only a single one,
but when, if you apply both of
them, basically you hear them.
If you play the signals
of different frequencies,
if these signals
are close enough,
close so that, as Josh
mentioned about the beats,
they happen within
one critical band,
again, neither blue
or green signal
would be heard on its own.
But if you play them
together, you hear them.
But if they are further in
frequency, you don't hear them.
Same thing if these guys
are further in time,
you wouldn't hear them.
So this subthreshold
perception actually
is kind of interesting.
And we will use it.
Which we didn't
talk much about is
that there are obvious
ways how you can modify
the threshold of hearing.
Here we have a target.
And since it is higher
than threshold of hearing,
you hear it.
But if you play another
sound called masker,
you will not hear it, because
your threshold basically
is modified.
It's called the mask threshold.
And this part is suddenly not--
this target is not heard.
The target can be
something useful,
but in mp3, it can
be pretty annoying,
because it's typically noise.
You try to figure
out how you can mask
the noise by the useful signal.
You're computing these
masked thresholds on the fly.
The initial
experiment with this,
what is called simultaneous
masking, was following,
and, again, was Bell Labs,
Fletcher, and his people.
They would figure out
what is the threshold
of certain frequency
without the noise.
But then they would
put noise around it,
and the threshold had to go
up, because there was a noise,
so there was masking.
Then they made a broader noise,
and threshold was going up,
as you would expect.
There was more noise, so you
had to make the signal stronger.
And you made it to
a certain point,
when you start making the
band of noise too wide,
suddenly it's not
happening anymore.
There is no more
masking anymore.
That's how they came with
this concept of critical band.
Critical band is what happens
inside the critical band
matters, basically, influences
the decoding of the signal
within a critical band.
But if it happens outside the
critical band, it doesn't.
So essentially, if the signals
are far away in frequency,
they don't interact
with each other.
And again, this
is a useful thing
for speech recognition people.
They didn't much realize
that this is the main outcome
of the masking.
Critical bands, I mean, again,
I mean, discussions are here,
but this is a Bark scale which
has been developed in Germany
by Zwicker and his colleagues.
It's pretty much regarded to be
from about 600, 700 hertz up.
And it's approximately
constant up to 600, 700 hertz.
If you talk to Cambridge people,
Brian Moore, and that sort
of logarithmic it's
pretty much regarded
to be pretty much everywhere.
But not really, but
the critical bands,
remember, critical bands
from the subthreshold things?
Again, the critical
band is masking.
It's starting it
with things happen
within the critical band.
They integrate.
They happen outside the--
each of them outside
the critical band,
they don't interact.
Another masking is
temporal masking.
So you have a signal--
and of course,
if you put a mask on it,
it's simultaneous masking.
You have to make it much--
the signal much stronger in
order for you to hear it.
But it also influences
things in time.
This is what is called
forward masking.
And this is the one which
is probably more interesting
and more useful.
It's also backward masking,
when a masker happens
after the signal,
but it probably
has a different origin,
more like cognitive
rather than earlier.
So there is still a masker.
You have to make the signal
stronger up to a certain point.
When the distance between
masker and the signal
is more than 200
milliseconds, there
is like there's
no masker anymore.
Basically, there is no
temporal masking anymore,
but it is within this
interval of 200 milliseconds.
If you make mask stronger,
masking is stronger initially,
but it also decays faster.
And again, it decays after
about 200 milliseconds.
So whatever happens outside
this critical interval,
about a couple of
hundred millisecond,
it doesn't integrate.
But if it happens inside
this critical interval,
that seems to be influencing--
these signals seem to be
influencing each other.
And again, I mean,
you know, I talk
about the subthreshold
perception--
if there were two tones which
happen within 200 millisecond,
neither of them would
be heard in isolation,
but they are heard if
you play them together.
Another part which is
kind of interesting
is that loudness
depends, of course,
on the intensity of the sound,
but it doesn't depend linearly
on that.
It depends with
about cubic root,
so in order to make a
signal twice as loud,
you have to make it
about 10 times more
in intensity for
stimuli which are longer
than 200 milliseconds.
Equal loudness curves,
this is a threshold curve,
but these equal loudness
curve are telling you what
the intensity of
the sound-- sorry--
would need to be in order
to hear it equally loud.
So it's saying that, if you have
a 40 dB signal at 1 kilohertz,
and you want to make it
equally loud at 100 hertz,
you have to make it
60 dB, and so on.
These curves become flatter
and flatter, most pronounced
at the threshold at lower
levels, but they are there.
And they are actually kind
of interesting and important.
Hearing is rather non-linear.
Properties depend
on the intensity.
Speech of course is happening
somewhere around here where
the hearing is more sensitive.
That was the point here.
Modulations, again, we
didn't talk much about that,
but modulations
are very important.
Since 1923, it's
known that hearing
is the most sensitive to
certain rate of modulations
around 4, 5 hertz.
These are experiments from Bell
Labs repeated number of times.
So this is this for
a, a modulations.
This experiment, what you do
is, that you modulate a signal,
and change the depth,
and change the frequency.
And you are asking, do
you hear the modulation
or don't you hear
the modulation?
Very interesting--
interesting thing
is, if you look
at-- again, I mean,
I refer to what Josh was
telling you in the morning.
If you just take one
trajectory of the spectrum,
you treat it as a time domain
signal, remove the mean
and compute its Fourier
components-- frequency
components, they peak
somewhere around 4 hertz,
just where the hearing
is the most sensitive.
So hearing is not very
sensitive, obviously,
to when the signal
is non-modulated,
but also there is-- there
are almost no components
in the signal which would be
non-modulated, because when I
talk to you, I move the mouth.
I mean, I change the things.
And I change the things about
four times a second, mainly.
When it comes to speech,
you can also compute--
music, you can also
figure out what
are the natural
rhythms in the music.
I stole this from, I
believe, the Munich group,
from [INAUDIBLE].
He played 60 pieces of music.
And then he asked people to
tap to the rhythm of the music.
And this is the
histogram of tapping.
Most of the people,
for most of the music,
tapping was about
four times a second.
This is where the hearing
is most sensitive.
And this is modulation
frequency of this music.
So people play
music in such a way
that we hear it well,
that it basically
resonates with the
natural frequency which
we are perceiving.
You can also ask
the similar thing.
So, in speech, you can
play the speech sentences.
And you ask people to tap in
to the rhythm of the sentences.
Of course, what gets out
is the syllabic rate.
And syllabic rate
is about 4 hertz.
Where is the
information in speech?
Well, we know what
the ear is doing.
It analyzes signal into
individual frequency bands.
We know what Homer
Dudley was telling us.
When messages and
modulations of these
frequencies-- as
a matter of fact,
that was the base
of his vocoder.
What he also did was that
he designed-- actually,
it wasn't only him.
There was another technique.
This one is, kind of,
somehow cleaner thing,
which is called the
spectrograph, which tells you
about the spectrum of
frequency components
of the acoustic signal.
So you take the signal.
You put it through a
bank of bandpass filters.
And then here, you
basically display,
on the z-axis, intensity
in each frequency band.
This was, I heard,
used for listening
for German submarines,
because they
wanted to-- they knew that
acoustic signatures were
different for friendly
submarines and enemy
submarines.
People listen to it--
for it, but also people
realized it may be useful
to look at the signal--
acoustic signal somehow.
Waveform, it wasn't making
all that much sense,
but the spectrogram was.
Danger there was that the people
who were working in speech
got hold of it.
And then they start, sort of,
looking at the spectrograms.
And they say, haha, we are
seeing the information here.
We are seeing the
information in waves.
The spectrum is changing,
because not only that this
was the way the origin
of the spectrogram
was developed, that you
were displaying changes
in energy in individual
frequency bands,
but you can also look at this.
This when you get to what is
called a short-term spectrum
of speech.
And people said, oh,
this short-term spectrum
looks different
for R than for E,
so maybe this is the
way to recognize speech.
So indeed, I mean,
those are two ways
of generating the spectrograms.
I mean, this was the original
one, bank of bandpass filters.
And you were displaying the
energy as a function of time.
This is what your ear is doing.
That's what I'm saying.
This is not what
your ear is doing,
that if you take a short
segments of the signal,
and you compute the
Fourier transform,
then you display the Fourier
transform one frame at a time,
but this is the way most of
the speech recognition systems
work.
And I'm suggesting that maybe we
should think about other ways.
So now we have to deal
with all these problems.
So we have a number
of things coming
in in the form of the message
with all these chunk around it.
And machine
recognition of speech
would like to transcribe the
code which carries the message.
This is a typical example
of the application
of speech recognition.
I'm not saying this
is the only one.
There are attempts to
recognize just some key words.
There are attempts
to actually generate
the understanding of what
people are saying, and so on,
but we would be
happy, in most cases,
just to transcribe the speech.
Speech has been produced
to be perceived.
We already talked about it.
It evolved over millennia to
fit the properties of hearing.
So this is-- I'm sort of
seconding what Josh was saying.
Josh was saying, you can
learn about the hearing
by synthesizing stuff.
I'm saying you of learn
about hearing by trying
to recognize the stuff.
So if you put something in
and it works, and it supports
some theory of hearing, you may
be kind of reasonably confident
that it was something
which has been useful.
Actually there's a paper
about that, which, of course,
I'm co-author, but I
didn't want to show that.
I thought I would
leave this one,
but I didn't do
it at last minute.
Anyways, speech
recognition-- speech signal
has high bit-rate,
recognizer comes
in, information, low bit-rate.
So what you are doing
here, you are trying
to reorganize your stuff.
You are trying to
reduce the entropy.
If you are reducing
the entropy, you better
know what you are doing,
because otherwise, you
get real garbage.
I mean, that's, kind of, like,
one of these common sense
things, right?
So you want to use
some knowledge.
You have plenty of knowledge
in this recognizer.
Where does this
knowledge come from?
We keep discussing
it all the time.
It came from textbooks,
teachers, intuitions, beliefs,
and so on.
And its a good thing
about that, that you
can hardwire this
knowledge so that you
don't have to learn it, relearn
it next time based on the data.
Of course, problem is that this
knowledge may be incomplete,
irrelevant, can be plain
wrong, because, you know,
who can say that whatever
teachers tell you,
or textbooks tell, or your
intuitions or beliefs is always
true?
Much more often now,
what people are using
is that they-- that knowledge
comes directly from the data.
Such knowledge is
relevant and unbiased,
but the problem is that you
need a lot of training data.
And it's very hard to get
architecture of the recognizer
from the data, at
least, I don't know
quite well how to do it yet.
So these are two things.
And again, I mean, let
me go back to '50s.
First knowledge-based recognizer
was based on the spectrograms.
There was Richard Galt.
And he was looking
at spectrograms
and trying to figure out how
this short-term spectrum looked
like for different
speech sounds.
Then he thought he would make
this finite state machine,
which will generate the text.
Needless to say, it
didn't work too well.
He got beaten by data-driven
approach, where people
took a high-pass filter
speech, low-pass filter speech,
displayed energies from
these to two channels
on, at the time it
was oscilloscope.
And they tried to figure
out what are the patterns.
They tried to
memorize the patterns,
make the templates
from the training data.
And they tried to match it for
the test data was recognized,
which was recognizing
ten digits.
And it was working
reasonably well,
better than 90% of the time for
a single speaker, and so on,
and so on.
But it's interesting
that, already in '50s,
the data-driven
approach got beat
by the knowledge-based approach,
because knowledge maybe wasn't
exactly what you needed to use.
You were looking at the shapes
of the short-term spectra
basically.
Of course, now, we are
in 21st century, finally.
Number of people say,
this is the real way
of recognizing speech.
You take the signal as it
comes with the microphone.
You take the neural net.
You put a lot of
training data, which
contain all sources of unwanted
variability, basically, what
you--
all possible ways of--
you can disturb the speech and
comes out the speech message.
The key thing is, I'm not
saying that this is wrong,
but I'm saying that, maybe this
is not the most efficient way
of going about it,
because, in this case,
you would have to retrain
the recognizer every time.
It's a little bit like,
sort of, you know,
if you look at the hearing
system, or the simple animal
system--
this is a moth here.
Here it changes in
acoustic pressure
to changes in firing rate.
It goes to very simple
brain, very small one.
You know, this is not the way
the human hearing is working.
Human hearing is
much more complex.
And again, Josh already
told us a lot about it,
so I won't spend much time.
The point here is, the human
hearing is frequency-selective.
It goes through a
number of levels.
This is very much along the deep
net and that sort of things.
But still, there is
a lot of structure
there in the hearing system.
So it makes at least
some sense to me,
if you want to do what people
are doing more and more,
and there will be a whole
special session next week
at Interspeech on how to
train the things directly
from the data, probably
you want to have
highly-structured environment.
You want to have a convoluted
pre-processing recursive
structures, and so on, and
long, short-term memory.
Yeah, here are actually
some, but all these things
are being used.
And I think this is
the direction to go.
But I still argue
that maybe it's
a better-- there's a
better way to go about it.
A better way to go
about it is that you
try first to do some
pre-processing of the signal
and derive some way of
describing the signal more
efficiently, using the
features, and so on, and so on.
Here you put all the
knowledge which you possibly
may want to--
you already have.
This knowledge can be derived
from some development data,
but you don't want to use
directly the speech signal
every time you are using--
you don't want to
retrain, basically,
every time, directly
from the speech signal.
You want to reserve
your training
data, the task-specific
training data,
to deal with the effects
of the noise which
you don't understand.
This is where the
machine learning comes.
I'm not saying that this is
not a part of machine learning,
but, I mean, this is--
there are two different things
which you are going to do.
I was just looking
for some support.
This one came from Stu
Geman from Brown University
and his colleagues.
Stu Geman is a machine
learning person, definitely,
but he says, we feel that
meat is in the features
rather than in the
machine learning,
because they go
overboard, basically,
explaining that, if you just
rely on machine learning, sure,
you have a neural net
which can approximate just
about any function,
given that you
have infinite amount of data
an infinitely large neural net.
And they say, infinite is a
kind of not useful engineering
concepts.
So they feel like that, if
representations actually are--
I hope they still feel the same.
I didn't talk to
them now, but it
seems like that there is some
support in this notion, what
I'm saying.
But of course, problem
with the features
is following, whatever you
stripped on the features,
this is a bottleneck.
Whatever you decide that is
not important is lost forever.
You will never recover
from it, right?
Because I'm asking for
feature extraction.
I'm asking for this emulation
of the human perception, which
strips out a lot of
information, but I still
think that we need
to do it if we
want to design a useful
engineering representations.
The other problem, of course,
is whatever you leave in,
the noise, the information which
is not relevant to your task,
you will have to
deal with it later.
You will need to train
the old machine on that,
so you want to be
very, very careful.
You are walking
a thin line here.
What is it that I
should leave out?
What is it that
I should keep in?
It's always safer to keep a
little bit more in, obviously.
But this is the goal
which we have here.
And I wanted to say,
features can be designed
using development data.
And when I'm saying use
the development data,
design your features
and use them.
Don't use this
development data anymore.
We have a lot of data for the
designing of good features.
And I think that, again,
is happening in the field--
good.
How the speech recognition
was done in 20th century,
this is what I know, maybe, the
most, so we'll spend some time.
And it's still done largely in--
there are some variants of this
recognition that's still done.
You take the signal.
And you derive the features.
In the first place,
you derive what
is called short-term
features, so you
take short segments of
the signal, about 10
to 20 milliseconds.
And you derive some
features from that.
That was in 20th century.
Now we are taking
much longer segments,
but we'll get into that.
But you derive it
with about 100 hertz
sampling every 10
millisecond, so you
turn the one-dimensional signal
into two-dimensional signal.
And here, typically, the
first step is the frequency,
so those may be-- imagine
those are frequency vectors,
or something derived
from frequency vectors,
gets through or stuff like that.
Those are just tricks,
signal processing tricks
which people use--
but one-dimensional
to two-dimensional.
Next thing is, you estimate the
likelihood of the sounds each
10 millisecond.
So here, what I--
imagine that here we have
different, say, speech sounds,
maybe 41 phonemes, maybe 3,000
context-dependent phonemes,
and so on, depends on--
but those are parts of speech
which makes some sense.
And they come, typically,
from phonetics theory.
And we know that
you can generate
different words putting phonemes
together in different ways,
and so on, and so on.
So suppose for the
simplicity that they
are-- there's 41 phonemes.
And so if there
is a red one, red
means that, probably,
posterior probability of the--
actually, we need them more.
We need the likelihoods
rather than posteriors,
so with your posteriors, we
just divided it by priors
to get the likelihoods, so
meaning that this phoneme has
a high likelihood
and white ones don't
have a likelihood at this time.
So next step is that
you do the search on it.
This is a painful part.
And I won't be spending
much time on that.
I just want to give you
some flavor of this.
You try to find the best
path through this lattice
of the likelihoods.
And if you are lucky,
the best part, then,
is going to present
your speech sounds.
So then the next thing is only
that you look and transcribe
to go from phonemic
representation from
into lexical
representation, basically,
because you know there
is typically one-to-one
relations--
Well, should be
careful, one-to-one,
but it is a relation, known
relation between phonemes
and the transcription.
So we know what has been said.
So this is how the speech
recognition is done.
Talking about this
part, I mean, here we
have to deal with one
major problem, which is,
like, the speech doesn't
come out this way.
It doesn't come out as a
sequences of individual speech
sounds, but, since I'm talking
to you, I'm moving the mouse.
I'm moving the
mouse continuously.
There is a thing that first I
can make certain sounds longer,
certain sounds shorter.
And then I add some noise to it.
Finally, because of what
is called co-articulation,
each target phonemes gets spread
in time, so you get a mess.
But people say--
sometimes, people
like to say, speech recognition,
this is our biggest problem.
I claim to say this
is not the problem.
It is a feature.
And feature is important,
because it comes quite handy
later.
Hopefully, I will
convince you about it.
But what we get is a mess, so
this is not easy to recognize,
right?
We have co-articulations.
We have speaker dependencies,
noise from the environment,
and so on, and so on.
So the way to deal
with it is to recognize
that different people
may sound different,
communication and
environment may differ,
so the features will be
dependent on a number
of things, on
environmental problems,
on who are saying
things, and so on.
People say same things
in different speech.
I can speak faster,
I can speak slower,
still, the message is the same.
So we use what is called the
Hidden Markov Model, where
you try to find such a sequence
of the phonemes which optimizes
the conditional probability
of the model, given the data.
And models you
generate, on the fly,
as many models as possible,
actually, an infinite number
of models, but, of
course, again, you
can't do it infinitely, so
you do it in some smart ways.
And this is being computed
through modified Bayes' rule.
Modified is because,
for one, I mean,
you would need a prior
probability of the signal,
and so on.
We don't use that.
But also, what we are doing, we
are somehow arbitrarily scale
the things which are called the
language model, because this
is a prior probability of
the particular utterance.
This is the likelihoods
coming from the data,
combining these two things
together, and finding the best
match, you get the output
which best matches the things.
Model parameters are typically
derived from the training data.
Problem is, how to find
the unknown utterance.
You don't know what is
the form of the model.
And you don't know
what is the data.
So we are dealing with
what is called the Doubly
stochastic model, a
Hidden Markov model.
Speech is a sequence-- it's
a sequence of hidden states.
You don't see this hidden state.
And also, you don't know
what comes from any state.
So it somehow-- so you don't
know for sure in which state
you are on.
You don't know for sure what
comes out, but you know that--
well, you know, you
assume that this
is how the speech looks like.
So here I have a
picture a little bit.
I apologize for being
trivial about this,
but imagine that you
have a string of--
group of people.
They are-- some are
female, some are male.
They are groups of
males, groups of females.
And each of them says something.
He says, hi.
And you can measure something.
This is a fundamental frequency.
You get some measurement out of
that, but you don't see them.
But what you know is that
they interleave, basically.
For a while, there
is a group of males,
then there is a-- then the
speech is to a group of female.
And then you stay for a
while in a group of female,
and so on, and so on.
So basically-- and
you know what is
the probability of the
fundamental frequency
for males, so some distribution.
So you know what is the path
on the fundamental frequency
for females.
You know what is the probability
of the first group being male.
Subsequently, you also know
what is the probability of the
[AUDIO OUT]
Because, to me, the features
are the important as I
told you, in which
we don't need,
but we don't want to take
out stuff that you may need.
I told you that that
one important role
of the perception
is to eliminate
some of this information.
Basically that's to so,
eliminate irrelevant focus
on irrelevant stuff.
So this is where I feel the
properties of perception
can come in very strongly,
because this is what emulates
this basic process
of the speech,
of the extraction of
information [INAUDIBLE]..
Especially about the
Hidden Markov models,
that speech consists of
the sequences of sounds
and they can be previously
different speed,
and other things.
It's important.
But here, we can use
a lot of our model.
Those features which can be
also designed based on the data.
And what comes out
is probably going
to be irrelevant to
speech perception,
so this is my point for how
you can use your engineering
to verify our theories
of speech perception.
We use largely,
nowadays, the neural
nets to derive the features.
So how we do it is that we
sort of-- because we know
that best set of features are
posteriors of the class we want
to recognize our speech sounds,
maybe it's going to be useful.
If you do a good
job, actually you
can do the reasonable sound.
So if you take a signal, you
do something processing--
and I will be talking about
signal processing quite a lot.
But then it goes into neural
net, nowadays, deep neural net,
and you estimate a posterior
use of different speech sounds.
And then what comes out,
whatever, it's always
is the high posterior
probability of the phoneme,
so we have you do it [INAUDIBLE]
sequence of the phoneme.
As the classes you can
use, directly context
independent in this
example, small number.
You can use context
dependent phonemes, which
I use quite a lot, because
they've tried to optimize this
despite that, if the
phoneme is produced
depends on what happened
inside, in the neighborhood,
[INAUDIBLE]
These posteriors can be
directly used with our research.
This is the search through
the lattice of the likelihoods
in recognition.
And again, I mean,
it's coming back.
This was the late 1990,
but this is the way
that most of this
recognizers work.
This is the major way now how
you do this feature cognition.
There's another way, which is
called bottleneck or tandem--
we were involved in that too--
which was the way to make the
neural nets friendly to people
who were used to old
generative HMM models,
because you
basically convert it,
your outputs from
the posteriors,
into some features which
your generative HMM
model would like for you.
What you did for you
de- correlated them,
you coercionized them so that
they have a normal distribution
and use it as a features.
And bottom line is, if you
get the good posteriors,
you will get the good features.
And we know how to use them.
And this is pretty much
the mainstream now.